[Music]
I told you that I want to go to that
festival in Sweden no you said it would
be cool to go yeah and then I got the
opportunity and I decided to do it you
going I just wish he would have told me
that's all do it she needs a therapist
you've been wanting out of this stupid
relationship for like a year now and
don't forget about all of the beautiful
Swedish women you'll need in June okay
guys that's not her again seriously babe
what's happening Danny
I was so very sorry to hear about what
happened I was doing I invited Danny to
come to Sweden you know what she's been
going for Christian says you've got this
special week planned it's sort of a
crazy festival special ceremonies and
dressing up kissing is fun
[Music]
unbelievable welcome a happy midsummer
school what time is it 9:00 p.m. that
can't be right the skies blue this is
what 9 p.m. is like here how long have
you two been together just over three
and a half years four years really yeah
what do you think it's like another
world tomorrow's a big day is it scary
what is it it has special properties
what am I going through we just need to
acclimate I don't want to acclimate I
want to go
absolutely not what's happening
that's why you look so guilty right now
because you know
we only do this every 90 years
I was most excited for you to come
[Music]